Let's see if we can
simplify 6 to the 1/2
power times the fifth
root of 6 and all
of that to the third power.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and try it on your own.
So let me actually color
code these exponents, just
so we can keep track of
them a little better.
So that's the 1/2 power in blue.
This is the fifth
root here in magenta.
And let's see.
In green, let's think
about this third power.
So one way to think
about this fifth root
is that this is the
exact same thing
as raising this 6
to the 1/5 power,
so let's write it like that.
So this part right over
here, we could rewrite as 6
to the 1/5 power, and
then that whole thing
gets raised to the third power.
And of course, we have
this 6 to the 1/2 power
out here, 6 to the 1/2 power
times all of this business
right over here.
Now, what happens if we raise
something to an exponent
and then raise that whole
thing to another exponent?
Well we've already seen in our
exponent properties, that's
the equivalent of raising this
to the product of these two
exponents.
So this part right over
here could be rewritten
as 6 to the-- 3 times 1/5
is 3/5-- 6 to the 3/5 power.
And of course, we're multiplying
that times 6 to the 1/2 power.
6 to the 1/2 power times
6 to the 3/5 power.
And now, if you're
multiplying some base
to this exponent and
then the same base
again to another
exponent, we know
that this is going
to be the same thing.
And actually we could put these
equal signs the whole way,
because these all
equal each other.
This is the same thing as
6 being raised to the 1/2
plus 3/5 power,
1/2 plus 3 over 5.
Now, what's 1/2 plus 3 over 5?
Well, we could find
a common denominator.
It would be 10, so that's
the same thing as-- actually
let me just write it this way--
this is the same thing as 6
to the-- instead of 1/2,
we can write it as 5/10.
Plus 3/5 is the same
thing as 6/10 power, which
is the same thing-- and
we deserve a little bit
of a drum roll here, this wasn't
that long of a problem-- 6
to the 11/10 power.
I'll just write it
all, 11/10 power.
And so, that looks
pretty simplified to me.
I guess we're done.